God,
praise be to God, and peace and blessings be upon the
best of speech, who calls to God and does righteousness and
says, "Indeed, I am of the Muslims." My Lord, expand for me my breast [with assurance] and
ease for me my task and untie the knot from my tongue that they may understand my speech.
Peace be upon you and the mercy of God and His blessings.
பீஸ் மச அஹ
கம் சஹஜர்
நாயக் அ பீஸ்டவிம் ஆ  I'm sorry I'm sorry
பரத அ  sிisterஸ்தி tringரோரம் weஹ 20
பாசிபன் கங் ரடி கட இன்ஸ்
பர்  இவல்கமிங்
஫ிரதர் இப்ராஹீம் குத்ரி ரம் யே பிரதர்
நாயக் ரம் இந்தியா
பிரதர் கைசிரோசுகி மோட்டோ  ரம்  ஜப்பான்
பிரதர் சபீக் அண்டி ரம் மலேசியா
பிரதர் அப்துல் கரம் சப்து ரம் நைஜீரியாத
আবদুল্লাহ  ফম মালেশিয়া
ব্রাদার ফেরদৌসং ওয়াইহ ফ্রম  মালেশিয়া
ব্রাদার আরশি গ
মোহাম্মদ হিসাম ரம்
আব্দুল মালিক ব্যাডগস
ডক্টর রেমান ইউনুস ফ্রম  ইন্ডিয়া ম
லேசியா
முஹம்மদி ரம் சிங்கப்பூர்
பிரதர் அஶ   பிரதர௏
மலேசியா
பிரதர் முஹம்மது இம்ரான் ரம் இந்த
அலாஸ்ல
யலிஸ்டர்ஸ்
20 பாசிபன்சி அரபியஜவச இன்ஷ
அல்லாஹ 19
இட் க முஸ்ம் அன்சுரன்
இlஷ قاري مصطفى انصاري
السلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان
الرجيم بسم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يا
أيها
الذين
امنوا
اتقوا
الله
حق
Fear God as He should be feared and do not die except as Muslims. O you who have believed, fear God as He should be feared and do not
die
except as
Muslims. And hold fast to the rope of
God
all together and do
not become divided.
And remember the
favor of God upon
you
when you were
enemies and He brought your hearts together, so you became
brothers by His favor. And you were on the
brink of a pit of
fire, and He
saved you from it. Thus does
God make clear to you His
verses that you may be guided. And hold fast to the rope of God
all together and do
not become divided. And remember the favor of God upon you when you were enemies and He brought your hearts together, so you became brothers by His favor. And you were on the brink of a pit of fire, and He saved you from it. Thus does God make clear to you His verses that you may be guided. And hold fast to the rope of God all together and do not
become divided.
And remember the
favor of
God upon
you
when you were
enemies and He brought your hearts together, so you
became brothers by His
favor. And you were on the
brink of a
pit of
fire, and
He saved you
from it.
Thus does God make clear to
you His verses that you may be
guided. And let there be among you a community inviting to good. And let there be among you a community
inviting
to good.
Among you are a
community that
calls
to
good, enjoins
what is right, and forbids what is wrong.
And it is they who are the
successful.
God
Almighty has spoken the truth. Peace, mercy, and blessings of God be upon
you.